esta noche se presentaron las dos
últimas películas en competencia de este
festival de cannes que comienza ya a
decir adiós ni trama una película
australiana basada en hechos reales la
matanza de port arthur un tiroteo masivo
ocurrido en 1996 mientras un joven ha
callado solitario que vive con sus
padres su vida cambia un poco cuando
conoce una rica heredera pero cuando
ella desaparece nuevamente vuelven los
problemas personales del joven sino la
otra película muy esperada esta noche
era los intranquilos un filme belga
protagonizado por actores franceses su
director joachim lafosse son conocidos
del festival de cannes sobre todo por la
manera en cómo tocan a los temas
familiares y de eso se trata esta
película una pareja donde el marido a un
artista plástico sufre de trastorno
bipolar sino esta noche también se
entregaron los premios de la sección a
paralela una cierta mirada el premio
para la mejor película fue para la rusa
racimo ya un lucky de la directora que
era kovalenko pero américa latina
también se llevó un premio a la valentía
para la directora rumana teodora and a
mi hija y por la película la civil que
cuenta la historia de una madre
la justicia en las manos para intentar
salvar a su hija raptada por el
narcotráfico